όσο μας επλήγωσείνα συμπεριφορά όποιο και αν πα σε πλήργωσε πριασυμπεριφερούμαστε μεα στα πλαίσατού της
απόφασης τού τον π τού τον προσπαθο να αποχορίσε ότι νασημεραδμο κρατικού συνακερμού θα στενοχωρούσεν
των ωράνιωνιο ανύρ ναι ναι στενοχωρείμαι μένα άρά θαντάζομε θα τον εστενοχωρούσε σίγουρα θα ναστυνοχωροσης
ότι ότι ότως και ο παντέρας μου ήταν νας άνθρωπος οποιος η αντίληψη τουγια τα
πράματα ήταν βλεπε ιο πολύ πιον προστά και μακριά που πρόσωπα και εκεινος νομίζω νομίζω
αυτό θα έκε το τον τον εστενοχόροσε ας πούμετο θυμούμε ότι των στονοχώρήσε πάρα παραπολύ
και ήταν πάνταστην άλλη με μια προσπάθεια συνένεσης για όλα α θέματα των καιρό που
είχαμε ρόμια πράγαο το δημο με τομετάδημο ψηφισμα μς πούμε τον εστυνοχωρούσε βέπε το θέμα
υπάρξει τη συνεργασίας μεονικ χριστό δουλίδη έκλεησε για το δημοκρατικό συνεριμό μιχάλημο ή ίσως αυτόν
αλλάξει κάπως για παράδειγμα τα ποσωστά τω βουλευτικώ δεν είναι αυτά που αναμένεται το θέμαν
συνεργασίας με τονικό χριστόδλίδ δεν βρίσκεται στον τραπέζι αυτή είναι μια πραγματικότηδα δεν συζηταί στο
κόμα δε συζία στο συναγερμό και δεν είμαι από τους ανθρώ εγώ όμως ε δεν
είμαι από τους ανθρώπους που μπορώ να πω ότι για ότι δήποτε σενάριον ότι δεν
υπάρχει θα υπάρξει ποτε στο μέλλο σήμερα δεν υπάρχει ούτε οποιο διποτεκακάταψε να τα έχουμε
λλοτρία χρόνιας το οσιόκτοδεν λέει κάποιος καδεδεδεν υπάρχει τευτιαφωνή μεσα στο κομμαόμως πρία κοταταλάβουμε τιαδί
ξε το ότι κάπνομε το της συζητο δήμου κάννεις τουν το ρότημα πρέπει κάποιο να
παντήσει του δημοσιογράφου καλή ώρα του